the squishes are still defending the fbi
and the doj even after the mar-a-lago
raid this is the this is a great rule of
thumb as to how you can tell a
conservative from a squish are they
defending the fbi are they defending the
doj
even after
six seven years of this but especially
after the mar-a-lago raid asa hutchinson
who's the squish republican governor in
arkansas he says look
fbi was just doing its job
the american public is operating uh
without sufficient information i think
we all have to take a deep breath and
say we're going to have to wait to see
the facts that come out there is some
urgency in it because
this is unprecedented the search of a
former president's home
the american public wants to understand
that and right now you mentioned the
circling of the of the wagons uh
around donald trump and it's simply
because they see the establishment as
going after donald trump and and they
questioned whether that was the right
move and whether it was less intrusive
means to accomplish the same purpose
we're going to have to be a little
patient
attorney general did the right thing by
getting information out this week well
the gop is going to be the party of
supporting law enforcement law
enforcement includes the fbi the fbi is
simply carrying out their
responsibilities under the law a lawful
search warrant
that a magistrate signed off on and they
didn't go in there with fbi raid jackets
they tried to constrain
uh their behavior carrying out that
warrant they're real i really think that
the republicans ought to thank that the
regime's secret police for going in and
raiding the home of the chief political
rival to the president the former
president unprecedented we should be
thankful
they didn't even wear their fbi jackets
because they were so ashamed of what
they were doing because they wanted to
hide the fact that the biden
administration was wielding the fbi to
attack the political opponents
we ought to be listen if we're going to
be pro
law and order
we need to support extremely corrupt law
enforcement agencies do we i don't think
that's true what are you talking about
no i
i support the fbi when the fbi is acting
in a just and proper manner i don't
support the fbi when it's corrupt
and there is no question that the fbi
has exhibited extremely corrupt behavior
in recent years
don't forget it wasn't obama it wasn't
the white house it wasn't even just the
doj it was the fbi that made up evidence
to get the the fisa court judge to allow
the fbi to spy on the trump campaign it
was the fbi kevin kleinsmith fbi lawyer
that did that i'm not saying it's the
regular agents on the ground i don't
think that's true i know a handful of
fbi agents who are good patriotic strong
conservative americans
but kevin kline smith he's not that
guy's worse than dirt that guy's a
complete rat who's who's who is
undermining integrity the integrity of
our law enforcement agencies and faith
that we have in the system that guy
doesn't deserve our support are you
kidding me
merrick garland the attorney general
who's just who's just operating as a
complete hatchet man for the biden
administration and wielding jack-booted
thugs to go attack donald trump that's
not that that's not back the blue that's
not the thin blue line that's corruption
we support the police
we don't support crooked cops
right we the most hardcore defender of
the police
the the really good policemen themselves
they're going to be the most outspoken
against the crooked cops because the
crooked cops give them a bad name same
goes for the fbi same goes for the doj
this guy don't forget asa hutchinson is
governor of arkansas he's the one who
defended transing the kids he refused to
sign a bill that said you can't trans
the kids anymore so this guy is just the
the clowniest of of fake republicans
this guy is the court jester in the
kingdom of liberalism par excellence
you don't want to be on his side you can
notice right now some of the moderate
republicans who had been leading leaning
in that direction of let this play out
we've gotta just whatever the fbi and
the doj do that's totally fine they're
starting to walk that back now because
they realize they don't want to be on
the same side as h asa hutchinson tim
scott who i like personally i think he's
a very nice guy he he really stepped in
it last week when he said that we need
to let the situation play out and not
rush to conclusions when the biden
administration is raiding trump's house
and he got a lot of criticism for that
rightly so now what's he doing he's
walking those comments back
sean this is absurd think about it this
has been a wish hunt for six years think
about the steele dossier the russia
collusion two failed impeachment
attempts
and even more i can't imagine how anyone
in our country doesn't look at this with
eyes of suspicion there's no question in
my mind that this is an overreach at
best and frankly asking for a criminal
warrant that gives you a space of time
between august the 5th and august 19th
because they're looking for
national security sensitive information
there's nothing that comes to the
conclusion that you would ever give
someone two weeks to go through that
process this is devastating we're in
unchartered waters it is stunning to our
country and frankly this is something we
have to continue to dig into we got to
win the majority sean so that we can
actually go through the oversight in the
majority of this process
okay that's really well said i couldn't
have said that better myself i really
like that tim scott i'm gonna vote for
that tim scott that's great
that's a 180 degree turn from what he
said on i forget which liberal news
program on which liberal network it was
last week but that's a 180 degree turn
last week he said well you know we got
to let this play out
we don't want to rush to conclusions and
then what's he do on sean hannity's show
on fox news he rushes to conclusions and
he says this is ridiculous and he's
right he's right the second clip is
correct so i'm glad tim scott gets total
credit he made a mistake he
went went back he corrected himself
now we got to make sure especially when
it comes to republican politicians i'm
not just singling out tim scott that
they're not just saying one thing to the
liberal audience and another thing to
the moderate audience and another thing
to the conservative audience we got to
make sure they're consistent what tim
scott said on that show is absolutely
right he makes a great point he says why
would the magistrate judge
that authorized this raid
give the fbi two weeks to undertake it
this is supposedly i mean now now the
libs have even dropped this kind of
argument but previously they were
insinuating through anonymous sources
trump had the nuclear codes he had this
is urgent sensitive information that's
why they had to raid trump they couldn't
wait for the lawyers to work it out
oh okay well if it was so urgent why did
why did the judge give him two weeks to
do it
furthermore if it was so urgent
why did the fbi get the warrant on
august 5th
and then they didn't undertake the raid
until august 8th
i was on a show on fox over the weekend
with the liberal brian tyler cohen and
he said oh michael you know come on it
was the weekend
it was the weekend hold on you're
telling me that this is urgent national
security sensitive information we could
be on the brink of nuclear war if the
fbi doesn't get these codes but well you
know i got to crack a few ones and and
have a barbecue with the family i'll get
it on monday i don't think so i don't
think so that doesn't really make a lot
of sense to me
people know the fbi looks terrible here
terrible
john ratcliffe who's the former director
of national intelligence under trump
he's suggesting that very possibly
because of how egregious this action was
by the fbi that christopher wray could
be the last fbi director
he said radcliffe says ray already
admitted that the fbi fraudulently
obtained multiple warrants to illegally
spy on trump as a candidate and during
the presidency if yet another fbi
warrant to raid trump's home doesn't
stand up scrutiny ray may be the last
fbi director this seems kind of
hyperbolic but i don't really think it
is the fbi as we know it today as the
fbi
only began in 1935 it's not that old
christopher wray is the eighth fbi
director
okay it's not
it would
it's not as though this institution's
been around since 1776 folks this is a
relatively modern institution before we
had the fbi we had a different version
of the fbi but it was structurally quite
different that that only even began in
1908 so yeah this this could change okay
the only reason that i don't think that
christopher wray will be the last fbi
director is because the republicans are
cowards and they don't want to wield
power
and you're even seeing right now some of
the moderates in the republican party
they're saying oh no we can't talk about
ending the fbi we can't talk about
radically restructuring the fbi no
that's crazy that's not well
what's the alternative what's you're
telling me that the alternative is we're
going to let the fbi just make up
evidence and start raiding the homes of
political opponents to go on fishing
expeditions to stop them from running
for president next cycle
you tell that's better that's more law
and order that's that's what serious
people do
rather than radically restructure the
fbi or get rid of it all together
i don't think so it
it'd be one thing if this were a one-off
incident this has been a consistent
pattern of behavior
for seven years now at least
forget about other abuses that the fbi
has undertaken it's not even only
against trump let's not forget
that the fbi contrived a an
assassination attempt kidnapping attempt
rather against gretchen whitmer the
michigan governor the democrat governor
of michigan who now the the uh
when the people were being prosecuted
for this the criminals who were kind of
entrapped and set up a number of them
got off the hook the ones who didn't
confess to the crime got off the hook
because it was such a bungle by the fbi
and so you're telling me we're going to
allow that to continue of course not
i wouldn't if i were in office right now
i think the your only responsible option
is to radically radically restructure
the fbi you've got to fire i'm not even
saying the regular agents on the ground
a lot of whom do a great job but you've
got to struggle you've got to
restructure the political leadership
that is perverting this institution of
law enforcement to only attack one party
to only go after one party on behalf of
the other party because the other party
the democrats constitute the
semi-permanent ruling class in the
united states right now go to tuvu.com
knowles it is time to take a stand and
stop feeding the big tech beast that
wants to cancel us all and censor us all
and isolate us from one another on
social media you've been hearing me talk
about touvu which is the new
subscription-based alternative that
weeds out the bots and the trolls and
the invasive ads and the algorithms that
make big tech such a toxic place tuvu is
the photo sharing community app built on
family values data privacy and freedom
of opinion it's time to move our
communities our families and our
churches to a better place online where
big tech is not pushing its woke agenda
it's vice it's addictive content and
it's damaging
mental health
accessories tuvu is ad-free so they
answer to you the subscriber on twoview
your data will never be sold to
advertisers and data miners instead
toovu sells social media freedom to
those who use it for just 2.99 a month
or 22.99 per year he who pays the piper
calls the tune that right there weeds
out the fakes and the bots and the
trolls are you hesitant to try a new
platform for the next seven days only
tuvu is giving our listeners a free
annual membership when you go to
www.toovoo.com
t-u-v-u dot com slash knowles get all
the details and your free annual
subscription
for a limited time only at twofu.com
knowles t-u-v-u dot com slash knowles or
look for the tuvu app on google play or
the app store
i'm so glad you like that clip you know
we hit 1 million subscribers and that's
great i feel fabulous that we are now in
the top youtube channels out there but i
want to go a little further i want a
billion okay the only way we're going to
get a billion you got a ring ding dong
slash smack like and subscribe hit the
bell whatever get the notifications
subscribe to the michael knowles show
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]